let's review a little bit of what we
know about exponents so if i were to
have three
to the second power
times three to the third power
times three to the third power what does
that equal
well we could expand it out just as a
review three to the second power well
that's going to be three times three
three times three and then three to the
third power and we're gonna multiply it
by three to the third power three to the
third power is going to be
three times three
times three so what is this going to be
equal to well this is going to be equal
to three
to the two plus three power
three to the two plus
three power
two to the three two plus three power
and this comes straight out of what an
exponent is this is we're taking two
threes and multiplying together and
we're gonna multiply that with three
threes being multiplied together so
you're going to end up with two plus
three or five threes being multiplied
together so this of course is going to
be equal to
this of course is going to be equal to
three to the fifth power
three to the
three to the 5th power and that's a
little bit of a review this is one of
the the core exponent properties if you
have the same base multiplied to
exponents and you're taking the product
of those two expressions you can
essentially or you do just add the
exponents three to some exponent times
three to some other exponent is going to
be three to the sum of those two
exponents so that's kind of interesting
but now let's use this property right
over here to try to think about what a
negative exponent should be so we're
going to try to think about what should
what should 3
to the negative
let's just say 3 to the negative 2 power
what should this be equal to
and i encourage you to pause this video
and think about it think about what
should this be equal to if we want this
property to hold that if you have the
same base raised to different exponents
that you can just take the sum
and you're taking the product of those
two expressions then you can take that
base to the sum of those two exponents
well let's try a little experiment here
let's try a little experiment what
should 3
squared
3 squared times 3
times 3
to the negative 2 power b
what should this be equal to
well if we want to keep this property
going this should be equal to 3
to the 2
to the 2
plus negative 2 power
2 plus negative 2 which of course would
be equal to which would be equal to 3 to
the 0th power
3 to the 0th power and any non-zero
number to the 0th power is going to be
equal to 1.
so this should be equal to 1.
so we should define 3 to the negative 2
in some way so that 3 squared times 3 to
the negative 2 should be equal to 1. we
need to do that if we want this property
to hold if we want this property to hold
right over there so let's just think
about what 3 to the negative 2 should
actually be so we want this to equal one
let me copy and paste that so that we
can we can manipulate it a little bit
algebraically so let me
copy
and let me paste it all right so we have
that on one side we want that
we want that to be equal to
1. and let me clean this up a little bit
we want that to be equal to 1.
so to define 3 to the negative 2 or to
think about what 3 to the negative 2
should be let's divide both sides by 3
squared let's divide both sides by that
so let me copy that
so we're going to divide this side by
that
and we're going to divide
this side by that and let me draw a line
so that you know that we're dividing
so we're going to divide the left hand
by that and the right hand by that well
3 squared over 3 squared those cancel
out and now we get a really interesting
result we get that 3
to the negative 2 power
3 to the negative 2 power should be
equal to
1 should be equal to 1 over
3 to the second power 1 over
3
to the second power and i really want
you to internalize this right over here
you have something to the negative power
to the negative 2 power in this case
that's equal to 1 over 3 to the positive
version of that exponent
and this is true in general in the next
video we'll use this a very similar
argument to prove this for for any
non-zero base and any exponent that
raising it to the negative is going to
be should be if you want this exponent
property to hold that you would add the
exponents when you were taking the
product of the same base raised to
different exponents if you want that
property to hold when you raise
something to the negative exponent it
should be 1 over that base raised to the
positive version of that exponent so 3
to the negative 2 power is 1 over 3
squared which is equal to 1 over 9.